pleasantness is the choice so why is it
so much unpleasantness is happened
because we never took charge of the
inner dimension we believe by fixing the
outside everything is gonna be okay in
the last hundred hundred fifty years
with the advent of science and
technology we have fixed too many things
on the outside if you fix anymore there
won't be a planet left I know you have
series of complaints about how things
are not okay but we are the most
comfortable generation ever before on
this planet we cannot say we are the
most joyful generation on the planet we
are the most loving generation on the
planet we are the most blissed-out
generations our plant definitely not
we are complaining like crazy about
everything like never before this is
because we fix the outside comfort and
convenience has happened well-being has
not happened if your interior tea was
handled by you consciously you would
definitely keep this in a blissful state
so is bliss the goal of life no bliss is
a necessary condition for life to flower
to its full potential
otherwise it will remain constrained
you're paying too much attention to
everything around you not enough
attention to this farm but the quality
of your life is essentially determined
by how you carried this one yes or no
this moment what kind of clothes you're
wearing what kind of car you parked
outside what kind of home you live in
does not determine the quality of your
life this moment how joyful are you
feeling within yourself determines the
quality of your life isn't it so nothing
has been done about it you think it'll
happen in consequence and you're setting
impossible goals for your happiness if I
have to be happy my wife should be like
this my husband should be like that my
children should be like this the world
should become some other way well these
are impossible conditions you're setting
for your happiness and peacefulness
to be peaceful essentially means this
that you're not messing your mind to be
peaceful means that your system is of
ease you know how to conduct your mind
you know how to conduct your emotions
your body and your energies you are
peaceful it is not a rocket technology
it is the most basic thing you just
watch - amazing clips from Sadhguru take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]